are we gonna do the gift
oh yeah let's do it let's go this is
what I did a gift though apparently not
do I need to play music do I need to
play music should I play music for it
yeah like what kind of music no we
should get like a nice uh I got it I got
I got it some like Oscars music
something inspirational you know like
Fanfare right yes at the fan fairy
something like this
there we go uh now to unveil this
wonderful gift okay sent to us
by the great Kitty bee I love kitty B
Kitty me rules what do we got here as we
unveil this folks ladies and gentlemen
get ready Papa
[Music]
oh oh
is that tiger thick that is Tiger thick
Papa
ladies and gentlemen black Kitty bee
folks
we got tiger thick tiger thick whiskey
well here's a question I have Marsh
obviously we need to do a taste are we
ready to get tipsy up here in the PF
Changs yeah I'm ready when do we do a
tasting hey
here open that up there open that bad
boy up yeah we're doing it we'll do some
tiger thick baby I I know that shit's
expensive it's not cheap it is it isn't
cheap uh Kitty V is a [__] lunatic
Kitty B just didn't want to be outdone
by the uh Jimmy Brown autobiography the
gym set I can't this is this is oh this
is good packaging by the way I like I
like my liquor uh I like my uh my cork
on the top to be sealed on with the
cheap plastic that you buy it like a
[__] cheap at Universal remote in the
bet the best thing about this merch is
you were literally a top tier alcoholic
so you will give this the most honest
[__] review I will give this an
honest review
does it have notes of Pico the guy okay
don't cut yourself it's a blend of
American and Japanese whiskey okay
it's gonna be hard to [__] that up
okay so is this here's a question I have
for you mark the packaging gets a oh
zero out of ten so so here's here's what
here's the question I have for you okay
I need you to tell me if this is a
shooting whiskey or recipient whiskey do
you understand what I'm saying
well we'll both do it I just want to
know I just want you to tell you're
gonna you're gonna be the better like
doesn't smell bad okay here we go
[Music]
there's a smile on Marsha's face like
honest the drink early but honestly it's
it's probably pretty good it's pretty
much Sandra Lee make a cocktail he's so
happier no wonder merch wanted to open
it so fast on the contrary I don't like
this because I I don't like starting
because then I can't stop there we go
all right here we go meet with Pringles
uh okay hold on hold on this is Mercer's
cup is chroma keyed mine is I'm awake
what more do you want
um it's a generic Mickey coffee Epcot
thing that's actually my coffee mug
what Aromas do you get what Aromas do
you get first it doesn't smell bad I'll
be honest with you it doesn't smell bad
to the homeless cats to the homeless
cats let's go
to Papa
[Music]
Murph poured a lot more for himself
import a lot more
there it is there's the American it
starts off Japanese whiskey and then you
get that American that's you know what
Pepsi actually described it perfectly
it's smooth at the beginning and then it
hits you and and I drink I could drink
whiskey I'm not a [__] when it comes to
that stuff
I don't hold on hold on hold on let me
tell a little more
[Music]
I give it a
I give it a six at a 6.5 out of ten it's
not all right
it's mid yeah Pat is cool it's mid it's
not
this isn't something I would drink I
certainly wouldn't buy it for the end
the end okay so here's the bra I'm I'm
just I'm not obviously not a pro like
you but
it's a little harsh the end the end
notes are hard does that make sense like
the beginning is actually hit smooth
okay that is a little too much Burn yeah
at the end it's a little like it's a
little too numbing it shouldn't be that
no it's definitely not as good as like
Jameson
hold on hear me out guys I got this
we'll do something here we're gonna make
we're gonna make we're gonna make the
Brennan shop special which is a ghost
and tiger thick let's see what we got
let's see let's see if it's if it's
better mixed you ready is that Swedish
Fish flavor better [__] believe it
here we go it's basically the breakfast
of Schwab champions
substantially worse yeah
no [__] it's actually worse yeah you
don't stay it tastes like Swedish [__]
uh Bowling Green Tampa man said I can't
believe no shot glasses in the studio
amateur as [__] boys it's because it's
his Studio he's not the alcoholic just
[__] kettlebells in here and [__]
all kinds of like weird [__] that he's
into I you know my shit's full of cat
hair and [__] you know wine glasses
what do you want
that was substantially worse cat hair
and wine glasses it was it just a joke
man because you know come on
um
it was [__] you know don't sandbag me
here it was right it was a very
important bit we're just promoting a
[__] tiger thick whiskey they might
make a clip of this and you're [__]
ruining it
you're ruining it wow this is this is
not good whiskey I'll be honest I'm not
doing it for the bit it's oh I would
have been been honest it's not the worst
it's not the worst I've had it's not
plastic bottle it's not plastic bottle
bad it's again I give it a 6.5
it's mid maybe a six you know it's not
again it'd be funny to just [__] on
Brendan's job and be like oh it tastes
like [__] poison it's all right but I
will put it this way because as people
know like I have fans on nightwave that
will either really yeah it's weird I
don't know why they'll send me money to
either go get a specific whiskey or
they'll send me a specific whiskey to
try and I'm always honest about them and
there's some that people send and you
feel bad going like that's not right but
you know they want it in my opinion and
there's been plenty of whiskeys I've
tasted where it's like uh you know it's
okay but I would never look for it I
would never go like hey you have tiger
thick hair because if not it's a deal
breaker like
um for instance um
what's the one that uh the the napog
Castle's one of them that's like it's
decent it's okay but it's like the price
I go yeah these are the ones that I
would get but if you served it to me I'd
go all right so I could drink this I'm
gonna my rating would be sick I would
say six even I would say six out of ten
in terms of like I mean I'm not as big
of a drink or as mercious but better
than his comedy
yeah yeah yeah it's this has a higher
rating than as IMDb on his last special
correct
I mean
Annie Letterman approved
this is the perfect this perfect whiskey
for a drug log I tell you they're in I
would tell you their Instagram but uh
big a lion got a band before he left so
anyway long story short great whiskey
never met him okay
what a surprise thank you kitty that was
that made my day that made my day that
really didn't say thank you kitty be hit
me up like before the trip as we were
leaving and she's like I want to ship
something is it the how is your house or
the P.O box easier and I'm like just
send it to my house you know what I mean
and uh so she was like get it she was
hitting me up as we're coming back on
the road and uh it was like as we were
overnighting back she was okay did you
check that like package and I'm like
no I haven't been home yet I checked the
tracking and it was literally the
perfect timing where it was like the the
morning I got back and we did the show
it was delivered during the show and I
was like I was don't [__] I was doing
totally I ain't telling nobody I'm like
I'm bringing that [__] in secret because
I wanted an actual reaction out of him
and uh it was worth keeping a secret so
thank you kitty it is actually you know
what a nice bottle too
like it's not a bad bottle there you go
Brendan it's not a bad bottle
um
oh now I [__] got a weird Swedish
whiskey burp yeah sorry about that no
that's not it was my fault for mixing
them I would have been fine if I didn't
mix them
yeah Zen Rhino the red breast is the
[__] that's that's the that's the
peak you get me a bottle of red breast
and that's like Ronnie B with his cigars
like if we ever had a Big Show at a
studio people can visit that's how you
brought me come up with a red breast
that's that that's the Ronnie B when you
come up with like a that's how Royce
brought them because Royce came from
[__] Cuban [__] iron I brought him
a cube an actual Cuban cigar they've
probably got an Opa Locka from some
[__] here you go yeah and he was like
all right you're in come on in
that's class